the story of the Scorpion and the toll
do you know that story no so and they
love this story and we acted out so
there's a toad right and he's swimming
around scorpion comes down and says hey
told him I need to get to the other side
of the stream and I you know I can't
swim
he says please help me and that toad
says oh I can help you because you're
gonna sting me I know a scorpions are
what is day one like for the workshop
FYI workshop what are you going over
first well day one my students are like
this like who you like some Hollywood
guy it so I need to tell us to make
films and they hey we don't want to make
Hollywood BS films like we want to make
the real we don't want to make fake
stuff so they are they resist me and
they when I say we're gonna make a film
they do these phobic till it's like what
is he talking about how are we gonna
make it film we're locked in here you're
feeding us some BS and like I mean I
show them film was made in the past
thing oh wow they become open to the
possibility that they really can write
direct and perform in a film whether
they're but so the first thing is just
icebreaker it's me getting them me
learning to dress them and then learning
to trust me and we talk about stories
for instance once though I start out
every day with the story of the Scorpion
and the toll do you know that story
no so um and they love the story and we
acted out so there's a toad right and
he's swimming around scorpion comes down
and says hey told him I need to get to
the other side of the stream and I you
know I can't swim he says please help me
and the tote says oh I can help you
because you're gonna sting me I know a
scorpions are let's score me says no
please toad I need to get to the other
side to the stream because my mom's sick
and they need to go see my mom and I
promise I won't show you that touch
there's no way I've heard about you you
always kill people when you get what you
want the Scorpion says no I promise I
won't kill you
just please and the scorpion starts
crying and I want to see my mom so the
talk goes over it says okay so the
scorpion gets on the totes back and they
serve him over in the Gannon on the
other side of the shore the scorpion
stings this toad and the toad dies and I
tell the youthful but it's the story
means it's an Aesop fable all you can't
trust scandalous people
all right once a liar always a liar
right so why do you want to get on the
back of somebody you can't trust unless
you really know them you should not
agree to get on their back so we we
start acting out like we have someone be
the toad someone be the scorpion then we
include like an eel who's just now don't
let him go on your back and then there's
an ego saying oh now I'll do it do it
you know and so we we basically explore
storytelling and the storytelling is
very very very powerful so the first
thing is pretty much about I let them
know that they're going to make a film
they don't believe me so then I saw them
films made by past youth and they
they're open up to it but they're still
kind of rigid and coiled but then once
we start doing these improvisational
where they play I base my teaching on
horn signal points Inga's essay about
how important play is for people
especially youth who have been through
trauma
look if you spend most your childhood
wondering when bullets are gonna come
through your window or when is the next
drive-by or or is your mama or your
daddy gonna get arrested there's no time
to play but the guy came into my room
was a guy from the burns Institute and
he's under he is researching why our
youth of color so over-represented in
California youth correctional facilities
why are black youths maybe 11.5 percent
of the California population yet they
represent 52% of the population of
incarcerated youth why why is that so
they came to my gymnasium once and they
saw black and Latino youth skipping
across the floor acting like a
melancholic elephant or a joyful leopard
or a confused dove or a drunk squirrel
and you create a space of
trustworthiness and where everything
that is said within
that group is sacred and there was no
wrong answer and nothing is wrong and
you create the space and then the magic
comes then they they open up but the
first day is really just about
icebreakers can I can I share with you
share with you one story please this is
we were talking earlier about animals
and in in my work with I did a couple
films with the youth mountain you tribe
the members of the get mountain ute
tribe in Colorado and I had a lot of
talks about the relationship between
human beings in the animal kingdom so in
this last workshop at camp a flyball I
noticed the kids were like really really
standoffish and really distant and doing
a lot of this I know I can't be he's not
serious this guy's a fake and a
rattlesnake in in our room and it was
all cold up and it was like ready to
bite anybody who came near it and one of
the kids want to kill her I said no no
no don't kill the snake because the
snake doesn't understand worry
where he's at he's in a gymnasium in a
youth Correctional Facility he needs to
be in the bushes or underground so we we
worked together and took the rattlesnake
and put him over the fence so he would
get away and I asked the kids I said
what do you think that route snake came
in I said I was confused I said well you
are the rattlesnake and they said what
do you mean I said because you guys are
called up like this and suspicious of us
I said I'm not I'm not criticizing you
I'm just making an observation
I said I'm coiled up too because I don't
know if you're gonna trust me so we're
all called up and like rattling but
we're not getting anything done so can
we let the root so then we did an
exercise where rattlesnakes and then I
said let's act like really trusting
rattlesnakes and they all stopped
rattling so I thought the opposite
sometimes the universe reflects what it
is we're going through when we were
working with other people in the middle
on the the midpoint see Saturday would
be day seven a California Brown
tarantula entered gymnasium and the kids
got scared I said hey it's a California
brown tarantula they will not bite you
they're not venomous they're they're
harmless so I
picked it up and mine start to Tyson
picked it up I said look it's not it
looks scary but it's not the kid said oh
that's just like us like a lot of people
out there think we're dangerous and
we're gonna hurt them but we're not we
just want to have enough to eat and we
want to love and be loved and we're not
always dangerous you know so that was
another example of the universe
reflecting what was going on between
instructors students and the last day
this is amazing the last date never had
this happen I've never had any animal
visitations during our workshops but on
the last day we were filming the last
tape and not one not two but three deer
come up to the fence and look at us and
I said cut cut and I said let's look at
the deers it's what what are the deer
what are they doing here I said I've
never had deer come up to me I've done
eight workshops at a football so what do
you think why are the deer here oh I
don't know it like Phil Mikkey like oh
there's something deeper than that I
think his animals we animals pick up on
they have that sixth sense no they don't
have a lot of the luggage we have as
humans what what are they saying
and I said let's look at in the deers
eyes and one of the kids said oh they
liked the fact that we're doing
something productive and good I said
you're right I said they're reflecting
back on your focus and when the deer
came two of them left but one sat down
until we finished and just watched us
and it created this feeling of
acceptance and gentleness and empathy
because deer are very gentle so that's
something to be noted and I actually
talked about in the doc how we had a
rattlesnake visit on day one the
California brown friends to visit in the
midpoint and the last day the deer came
and I also feel like the deer helped get
the youth to that place to connect with
their empathy because they said father
do you look really friendly like they
look like loving like they care about us
I'm like yeah that's the nature of deer
and it got them to think about what what
part of me can be like a deer how can I
be loving or
are sympathetic or be interested in
someone else's well-being those the
three I believe it was the three deer
that were very instrumental in getting
my students to that place I mean I've
never had animal visitations I had three
rattlesnake California and brown
tarantula dear you cannot ignore these
things now people think I'm kind of out
there but I know I pay attention to this
right right again the synchronous a is
these signs yep
whether it's just that you're noticing
them and other people don't think most
people they're too busy with the phone
they're looking at the latest like
celebrity baby news or something or you
know political scandal and and to being
open to seeing that were you always this
empathetic though or was this a long
process um yeah I been empathetic but I
think working with this population just
expanded my capacity for that you know
and I also think a life-changing thing
for me was doing the two films with the
you'd met you try by I I have a medicine
man his name is Waylon plenty holes and
we were having some really weird stuff
happened we were shooting in the youth
shelter and there was a lot of really
dark stuff happening like people having
negative thoughts people having been
overcome with anxiety people becoming
someone they weren't people breaking out
in hives and I call my medicine man and
said I need you to please help me and he
came in and did a blessing with the Red
Willow red Willowbrook bark and sage and
I I asked my medicine man I said what
what what was going on on that set I
said it was there was some negative
energy he said where you're filming many
youth who were abused I mean a youth
committed suicide and there's a lot of
negative energy around here so you were
feeling that so I had to have the
medicine man come and clean up the space
every day before he fell in he taught me
a lot about animals and how they
communicate with us and I think that
opened my eyes to I didn't know it
it just helped to expand my awareness
all my conversations with folks from the
state a ute mountain you traveling the
other since you're talking about
synchronicity my my Tia you can use this
or not use it but my Tia my aunt told me
before I went to Colorado three years
ago as you said you're gonna have a hard
time this is gonna be very challenging
thing because life on the rez is really
tough it's really it's really hard for
me to talk about because I don't like
seeing young Peavy anyone suffer so she
said you you will have an ally it would
be a you will have a male ally that will
help you overcome the negative forces
and I figured oh my Ally is chief Hart
it's definitely the chief because I get
along well with him and he's powerful
and he has he's like a shaman so when
this incident happened we were shooting
on the youth shelter I I called a
medicine man and said I don't know what
to do
there's some bridge stuff going on here
and I either have I can't cancel the
shooting I can't because we're not gonna
finish the film I need you to please
come and help me understand what's going
on so my my Tia said you have an ally
and he will welcome to complete
counterclockwise circles with you and I
said really
she said yes that's you have an ally and
you will know who it is when he walks
into complete counterclockwise circles
so when when Raylan came he had a sit in
a circle and we we smoked red willow
bark and we smoked sage and we had to
turn that the pipe counterclockwise that
we passed it around then he said I need
everyone to walk with me in one circle
so we walked in one a counterclockwise
circle and I said to myself that's not
him he's not my ally because he's
younger than me you know he's like 32
like nods and I mean it's it's cheap art
so on the last day of my my last day in
Colorado I was told that when you ask a
medicine man or a medicine woman for
help they can't say no even if you are
their enemy they cannot say no also they
cannot charge for it they don't
understand like how in Western culture
you have to charge to see a doctor or
charge to see a therapist or charge to
see a psychiatrist because they believe
that if you have a gift to heal you
he'll you do not charge for it so I
figured okay I can't give him money so
I'm gonna buy gifts for all his kids so
I went to his house and gave the house
kids they made me a really beautiful
lunch and he said before you leave
before you head to the airport I'd like
to show you my my my property and he
said let's go and his wife and three
kids left and we walked around the
property and a complete counterclockwise
circle and I said you're my ally I said
I apologize because I rejected you as my
ally because you're younger than me but
you really are am innocent man and so
we're good friends now I call him for
advice sometimes he's the one to help me
understand the snake in the California
branch wrestling the deer so that
experience I had with the folks at the
youth mountain you tried to help to
expand open my eyes to what's out there
there's another realm out there that we
don't know about you talked earlier
about a higher hand so that really
helped me to evolve also helped me to
evolve as a filmmaker because on that
the day before the event of the youth
shelter a a man from the Apache Tribe
came up and said do you know what you
were doing with the young Native
American youth area I said yes he said
what are you doing I said I'm teaching
them filmmaking he said what else are
you doing I said I'm teaching them
storytelling he said what else are you
doing
I said I'm empowering them he said
there's something else you're doing
there's a prophecy with the indigenous
people there's 566 Native American
tribes in North America but all the
indigenous tribes from around the world
believe that this generation right now
18-under
they are the seventh generation that's
the generation that is going to wipe out
discrimination inequality human
suffering and so he said when you teach
young people you are preparing the
seventh generation to heal the world and
that made me recontextualize my approach
to how I teach so when I went to a flow
by I said hey these kids okay they made
bad decisions but they are going to be
healers walking this
earth according to the seventh
generation prophecy you're not hearing a
lot about it but it's coming more into
mainstream thinking a lot of there's new
companies called seventh generation but
so to think we think my role is not just
teacher or film teacher but nurturing
and cultivating protecting their gifts
so that they can go on and make the
changes in the world that we want may
not happen but it's going to be their
generation and this is the seventh
generation prophecy
you